تتحدث في الساعه الماضيه عن نسق جديد في
الاستهدافات وهو نسف وتلغيم المباني
السكنيه يضاف الى القصف بطيران الحربي
الان الزوارق الحربيه وايضا المدفعيه ماذا
في التفاصيل
هشام بالفعل ازدهار الجيش الاسرائيلي يكثف
من قصفه خاصه لمناطق خانيونس جنوب قطاع
غزه المناطق الشرقيه التي كان انسحب منها
الجيش الاسرائيلي او تراجع واعاد التموضع
في مناطق قريبه من الحدود من السياج
الفاصل اعاد التقدم فيها من جديد ويقصف
الان من جديد هذه المنازل المدنيه وهذه
الاحياء والبلدات بن سهيلا وخزاعه والقرار
وعبس وعلى مدار الاسابيع الماضيه كان
القصف الاسرائيلي شديد باتجاه تلك المناطق
لكن عندما دخل الجيش الاسرائيلي من محور
بطن السمين وجرت اللوت والمناطق الجنوبيه
الشرقيه لمدينه خان يونس ربما انخفضت حده
الغارات الاسرائيليه والقصف الاسرائيلي
المدف ع على تلك المناطق الشرقيه بني
سهيله وخزاعه والقرار وعبس الان الجيش
الاسرائيلي يعيد القصف في تلك المناطق
ينسف المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه هناك
وهذا ربما نستنتجه من اصوات الانفجارات
الناجمه عن القصف الاسرائيلي او حتى عن
تفجير تلك المنازل هذه سياسه يستخدمها
الجيش الاسرائيلي منذ بدايه الحرب
الاسرائيليه او حتى بالتحديد منذ بدايه
عمليه التوغل الاسرائيلي في مدينه غزه وفي
شمال القطاع كان ينسف المباني شاهدنا كيف
كان يتفاخر الجنود الاسرائيليين على وسائل
التواصل الاجتماعي كيف انهم ينسفون هذه
المباني كما نسف الجامعات في مدينه
الزهراء وايضا نسف عده منازل في مدينه غزه
وكذلك مؤسسات وجمعيات وحتى مساجد كان
ينسفها الجيش الاسرائيلي في مدينه غزه وفي
شمال القطاع الان ينفذ ذات السياسه في
خانيونس جنوب قطاع غزه وعده منازل
استهدفها الجيش الاسرائيلي على مدار
اليومين الماضيين في المناطق الشرقيه
وايضا كذلك في المناطق الجنوبيه الشرقيه
في منطقه ب بطن السمين لكن ايضا القصف
المدفعي رغم ان هذه التفجيرات مستمره
ومتواصله ان الا ان القصف المدفعي ايضا لم
يتوقف على مناطق مختلفه محيط مستشفى ناصر
هو بات محور الاستهداف من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي والمدفعيه الاسرائيليه كذلك
المناطق حي الامل وهو في قلب مدينه
خانيونس ايضا يستهدفه الجيش الاسرائيلي
بالقصف المدفعي كذلك محيط المركز التابع
للهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني محيط مركز الامل
و وهناك ايضا هو مستشفى وبالتالي القصف
المدفعي بات كثيفا على تلك المناطق ويمكن
وصفه بانه الاكثر حده والاكثر عنفا وبكل
تاكيد هناك اصابات حتى الان وشهداء لم
تستطع سيارات الاسعاف الوصول اليهم في
منطقه البطن السمين وجرت اللوت وهذه
المناطق التي استهدفها الجيش الاسرائيلي
بعنف ونفذت فيها القوات الاسرائيليه
عمليات تقدم وتوغل من وجديده وايضا اعاده
التمركز والتموضع وتراجعت بعض الشيء خلال
امس ولكن هذه العمليات ما زالت مستمره من
خلال القصف المدفعي وهناك ابلاغ عن عدد من
الشهداء والجرحى ما زالوا على الارض ولم
تستطع سيارات الاسعاف وسيارات الدفاع
المدني الوصول اليهم في ظل استمرار القصف
وايضا في ظل تحليق مكثف لطائرات مسيره
اكواد كابتر تطلق النار على المواطنين
وعلى سيارات الاسعاف التي تحاول الوصول
الى هذه الجثامين ايضا منطقه وسط قطاع غزه
ما زالت تتعرض الى قصف من المدفعيه
الاسرائيليه ما بين فينه واخرى مخيم
المغازي مخيم البريج المناطق الشرقيه
فيهما تتعرض الى قصف مدفعي ما بين فينه
واخرى وهذا القصف متزامن ايضا مع اطلاق
نار من قبل الزوارق الحربيه الاسرائيليه
التي تطلق النار على المناطق الغربيه
لمخيم النصيرات وكذلك منطقه الزوايده ودير
البلح